so I am tongima this quarter we are
going to have two instructors you know
me and Chris I I'm tonyma I work on
machine learning machine learning theory
um including the theory for different
topics machine learning reinforcement
learning representation learning
supervised learning so and so forth
um I guess I would like Chris to say uh
say something about him whatever he
wants to say yeah I'm Chris also the
machine learning group I'm really
interested in how systems we build are
changing with machine learning uh it's
been a really interesting time for the
last 10 years started a lot on
optimization how we scale up these big
models that was when machine learning
had very few applications in our in our
lives around you over the last couple of
years have built things that hopefully
some of you in this room have used my
students contributed to things like
search and Gmail and assistance and
other places there and more recently
really interested in how to make these
models robust and we'll have a great new
lecture that tangyu is going to give
about what are called Foundation models
or these large self-supervised models
that are kind of all the rage Percy and
a course about them last term and this
course is really exciting because it's
giving you kind of that absolutely
foundational layer of machine learning
that all that stuff is built on so this
is a great time to study it because it's
no longer abstract like you get to use
machine learning products in every day
and hopefully you'll get some insight
into how they actually work and and why
there's still so much research to do so
really excited and looking forward to
lecturing with you folks
great uh I guess you'll see me and Chris
alternate
um for every few weeks you know next
next lecture will decrease and then
after two or three weeks you can see me
um so to this lecture I guess I'm going
to
um okay I guess the first thing the
second thing is that let me introduce
the teaching team so uh we're gonna have
um 12 like fantastic Tas and the one
high ta and of course coordinator so
what is the high ta and it's gonna be
the course coordinator they will be
probably uh doing most of the works
behind the scenes you know you probably
don't necessarily have to interact with
them very often so they are organizing
the whole ta team and we have like 12
currently 12 Tas I guess probably we're
gonna have more if we have more
enrollments
um and I guess um I didn't ask the kids
to show up in the first lecture just
because I guess they also have to wear
masks and and maybe the pictures you
know serve the same need but I guess
you'll see them you know pretty often in
office hours and and different uh
scenarios
um cool so um okay so I guess the um
this lecture I think I'm going to spend
first probably 20 minutes on some of the
logistics some of the the basic kind of
like uh the structure of the course and
so forth and then I'm going to introduce
um the incredible at the high level the
topics that covered that is covered by
this course
so I guess um we tried very hard to make
everything available online like in a
single dock I guess on a single website
so we have this course website which has
links to a few different Google Docs
um one of them is about all the
logistical stuff and the other is about
the syllabus and the the final one is
about um
also there's the links to the lecture
notes and there's links to
um some kind of like guidelines on the
final project so in theory I think all
the informations I presented today you
know will be subside of what you can
found on the on the website and it's
actually a very small subset
um so I do encourage you to kind of like
read through the the documents you know
to some extent you know especially when
you have some questions you know maybe
first go to see whether the documents
answer those questions and and then feel
free to ask questions to us so
um I guess the first thing I'm going to
talk about is the prerequisite
um so this course you know as you'll see
will be you know at least the sum of the
students in the past say this course is
challenging of course some students say
it's on the easier side no
um there are different kind of
backgrounds you know um so I think
that's why we do this is my first slice
right because
um I think it's important for you to
have some kind of like a backgrounds to
be able to achieve your your goals in
this course so I think the most
important prerequisite is probably some
knowledge about probability on the level
Flex cs109 or size 116
now for example you probably should be
at least you should have heard of this
these terms like distribution random
variables you know expectation
conditional probability violence density
so and so forth right you don't
necessarily have to know exactly all of
them like off the top of your head but
this probably should be something you
have seen in one of the previous courses
another thing is linear algebra major
specification eigenvectors I guess
linear algebra was offered in mathml4
113 205 actually there's a longer list
of kind of relevant courses in the
logistic doc which you know taught
linear algebra and the most important
thing I think we need is measure
specification and eigenvectors
and we also require some basic knowledge
of programming especially in Python and
numpy so
um I think if you only know python but
not numpy I think that's probably pretty
much fine because numpy is really just
some basic you know numerical operations
but if you don't know Python and numpy
but you know for example C plus plus I
think that's still probably pretty fun
um because you know I think migrating
from C to python is is pretty relatively
easy in my opinion but you know um I
think they have similar kind of you just
have to change the syntax but if you
know nothing about programming I think
that's probably going to be difficult
because a lot of homework you know they
have some math part and they have some
programming part and one of them the
most challenging thing I've seen in my
past about homeworks is that when you
write a piece of code and something goes
wrong which happens all the time and
even when I write code you know there's
something that seems to be wrong and you
don't know whether it's about the syntax
or it's about math right so these two
things kind of sometimes entangled
together so so you saw that I did I
derived the wrong you know equations but
actually probably you didn't use numpy
in the right way so we're going to kind
of cover python numpy in some of the TA
lectures
um just to kind of give you some
refreshment or kind of like if you
didn't know them you can learn something
from the te lectures
um um so but but I think you need to
have some basic programming knowledge
um yeah so
um the tea lectures you know we also
have materials for the tea lecture so
you can
um like we're gonna have three lectures
on each of these topics
um programming in the algebra and and
probability to kind of review some of
the backgrounds for you
um I guess you know this is a
mathematical intense course you know at
least according to you know of course
depending on your backgrounds but kind
of like a good portion of students found
that uh this course is mathematically
intense
um so it's kind of a heads up so so it's
probably good for you to have at least
you know at least 12 out of these three
two like among the three things probably
you need to know at least two of them
um relatively well so that you don't get
kind of credit entangles kind of like
issues when you do the homeworks so
um yeah but that's kind of why this is
exciting and rewarding as Chris has said
the goal of this course is to give you
the foundations of machine learning this
is the foundational layer
um so so this is a
simultaneously introduction course to
machine learning we don't require you to
have taken a machine in the course to
take this right
um so so it's an introductory course but
on the other hand we hope that after you
take this course you feel somewhat
comfortable that you know like enough
basics of machine learning so that you
can apply machine learning to some of
the applications of course if you really
want to kind of be an expert in some of
the applications like nlpm Vision you
probably have to take those courses but
this course probably will set up the
foundations for the most learning
component of some of the the general
kind of like AI or other applications of
AI
right so so that's why we're kind of
like this course is actually covers a
diverse set of topics and and does
involve some mathematics we don't have
um mathematical proofs you know probably
we have a little bit proofs but very
little proofs but we do have a lot of
like mathematical derivations right you
probably have to follow
um like a do some kind of mass
derivations in the homeworks and we are
going to do the revisions in the in the
lectures as well
right
um by the way if you have any questions
just feel free to stop me
um um I'm happy to answer any questions
yes the lectures are recorded and you
can find the recording on canvas I guess
right so the second important thing that
I want to say is the owner code it's
probably a little kind of awkward to say
this you know um so early and I think
the reason is that in the past
unfortunately we do have some kind of
there are some issues with let's be
frank there's some kind of issues with
the owner code violations you know I I
don't want to see them you know it's
very you know side for me to to see the
to report to have to report students you
know with designer code violation but
that's what's you know that happened in
the past so so that's why I want to kind
of like put this up front
um you know if you don't intentionally
write Honor Code
um I don't think there's anything you
should worry about like
um but anyway let me briefly say you
know this is actually a subset of like
uh things that we have on the uh the
course website but I think these are the
important thing so um for example you
know on one side you know we do
encourage you to have study groups so
you can
um collaborate with other people on
homeworks or on on like uh homework
questions like um so but
um
um but the thing is that you can own you
cannot okay so you can discuss works on
homework problems in groups but you have
to write down Solutions independently
and you also have to write down the
names of people with whom you discuss
the homework
and I guess this is I'm copying this
from the logistic doc which is a little
bit longer you probably should read that
piece of text you know in the dock as
well so it's all the code violation to
copy refer to or look at written
or coding solutions from a previous year
including not limited to official
solutions from a previous year Solutions
posted online Solutions you or someone
else may have written up in previous
year solution for related problems you
know anyway
it should be fine
um but as long as you don't
intentionally kind of like do anything
bad I think you know don't be stressed
out about it but on the other hand they
were kind of like reporting of final
violations in the past so we do kind of
like check the code
um like like using some some kind of
softwares and also we we do we'll we'll
have Tas to kind of like deal with this
kind of honor code violations
too much stress about this but I don't
want to kind of like put it up front
here
um
okay so
um one another component I would like to
kind of like um besides homework and
homework is kind of like obvious where
we have to have homeworks another
component of the course is the course
project so we encourage you to form
groups of one to three people and
um so you do a project with three people
for example and it's the same Criterion
for either one people or two or three
people
so and there are more informations on
the course web on a website
um and typically you you apply machine
learning to some kind of like um
applications you know or some kind of
topics you are interested in right so
um this is actually one thing that I
really like about this course eventually
you know after every year every quarter
we got like probably 100 submissions
from the the projects and we see all
kind of topics you know
um um or like all kind of applications
of machine learning like these are just
a list of topics we have you know see in
the past and you are welcome to you know
even work on other topics right so of
course you can also work on just the
pure algorithms for machine learning
that's also fun but many people have
actually also work on applications of
machine learning uh to other kind of
topics like music you know Finance which
are kind of interesting
um
okay great so and we have homeworks you
know we have four homeworks you know
you'll see um you know uh and we also we
are also going to have a meter there is
no final
um uh exam so the
um so midterm cost project and homework
those are the main things for the course
um and another component of the course
is the TA lectures
um so these are optional uh you don't
have to attend them if you don't find
them to be useful and also there are
actually two sets of ta lectures so one
type of tea lecture is the so-called
Friday the lecture of Friday section so
um so we're gonna have problematicus six
to seven weeks of these lectures the
first three weeks will be about
reviewing some of the basics
um and especially the part of the basic
kind of concepts related to machine
learning and then the other weeks about
more advanced topics
um which are not required for the course
but maybe interesting for some subset of
you and we also have the discussion
sections the goal of this is to have
some interactive sessions our course is
pretty big right so you know you can
feel free to ask questions but I I guess
you know after bullet you know like it's
a bit less interactive per person
compared to other courses
um so we're gonna have this uh small
sessions led by Tas which the goal is to
kind of like imitate more traditional
classroom settings and also work on kind
of like a
um more kind of like Bridging the Gap
between the lectures and the homeworks
right so
um so basically the Tas will largely
work through problems that are very
similar to the homeworks or even
sometimes simpler than homeworks so that
if you
um if you need it if you need them you
know they will help you to kind of like
uh make it easier to solve homework
questions right so and I mean terms
so
um and this kind of sessions will be
more interactive like the Tas probably
will let you to do some questions live
and and maybe present your Solutions and
discuss with other students so and so
forth
um and the exact time and format will be
you can find them on the on the the dock
um the Google Doc about the logistics
oops Okay so
yeah so there are some you know many
other informations on the course website
on the Google Doc the dock is actually
15 pages now
um it's pretty comprehensive
um so for example recordings they can be
found on canvas
um there's a course calendar on canvas
there's a syllabus page which will link
to the lecture notes
um and
um
and we're gonna have like the the ad the
platform for question answering
um we do encourage you to use that to
communicate with us
um if that makes sense like a like
almost in all situations I think you
probably should use ads to communicate
with us you can have private posts or
another's post
um different type of posts depending on
what you need
um and if you don't have access to that
then you probably have to email some of
us I guess you can email the uh the ITA
too um to add you to the to that to give
you access to add
um and there's grid scope which is used
to submit homeworks and there are some
late take policies which you can find in
the the dock as well so I guess one
thing that I need to mention here just
uh as a heads up is that we don't allow
late days for the final project and this
the reason is just that especially for
spring quarter the grading deadline is
very tight so it's pretty much just a
few days after the the final the exam
week so especially because some of the
students have to graduate and they have
and it's the timeline is very very
strict so
um and we don't want to kind of like
make the course project deadline the
final project like very early right
because then that would kind of conflict
with the homework deadlines so and so
forth so so the final project I've done
I think is
on the I think it's on Monday of the the
finals week uh double check that but but
it's it's we try to put it as late as
possible but on the other hand because
the the final greeting deadline we don't
allow later is for the final project
uh and there are some other IFA cues you
know in the Google Doc as well
any other questions before I move on to
the topics the more kind of like the
scientific topics
foreign
we have two uh Tas uh offering two
discussion sessions I think we will try
to make sure that the materials in the
two sessions are pretty much the same
and the times are kind of like somewhat
kind of I think we haven't decided time
yet
um so you can feel free to choose any uh
sessions you want to go
um probably is the best for you to
consistently go to one session maybe the
Tas knows you better you know
um but you don't necessarily have to
and then this is also optional you don't
have to really say go to all of them
depending on your needs yeah
other questions
okay uh
okay sounds great so I guess then I will
move on to the more scientific part of
the course so as I said
um the main goal of this course is to
set up you for the foundations of
machine learning
um and we're going to cover a pretty
diverse set of topics immersion learning
with the you know some kind of
mathematical way
so let me start by um some definitions
of machine learning what is machine
learning right as you can imagine you
know when you are speaking about you
know such a kind of like hot topic that
is kind of like um that people are
constantly researching on right so
there's probably not unique definition
right so that can fit uh everything
right but I'm trying to find out some
kind of like historical definitions of
machine learning which I think describes
the field
um pretty well so in 1959 I think this
is probably the first time machine
learning the word the phrase machine
learning was introduced on by author
Samuel
um he says that machine learning is the
field of study that gives the computer
the ability to learn without being
explicitly programmed
so I guess without being explicit
program it's probably
um something pretty important for
example suppose I guess this is in the
paper titled some studies in machine
learning using the games of checkers
recent progress
I don't exactly know what the game of
hackers is so don't ask me about what
the rules of the the game but the point
is that if you explicitly
write a piece of code that play the
Checker right that doesn't really mean
that you are using machine learning
right so if you just say I have this
fixed strategy I know which is actually
very good for checkered the first step
would be this and the Second Step would
be that move right I just explicit code
that uh in my in my computer and with
some branching algorithms right so
um that probably doesn't count towards
machine learning right so uh if you use
machine learning you have to like the
computer to learn without being
explicitly programmed so you shouldn't
have explicit programming
so but how do you learn right how do you
give the computer the ability to learn I
think in the second definition of
machine learning by Tom Mitchell it's
kind of like describes more context or
more kind of like a
um like a context about you know how do
you really let the program to learn uh
without being explicit programmed I
think it says that a computer program is
set to learn from experiences e with
respect to some class of tasks T and
performance measure P if its performance
at tasks in t as measured by P improves
The Experience e the the rhythm is kind
of nice
um so um so I guess there are several
important Concepts in this passage so
one thing is that The Experience e right
so
so I guess let's still use this example
of the game of Checker so the experience
in this case could mean for example the
data so data basically means that this
policy could be games played by the
program
with itself it could mean games played
by humans in the past it could mean you
know other kind of like a data you
collected from other you know source of
information maybe you collect some data
from I don't know like uh in this case
maybe
um
um you know you can collect data from
other sorts of information maybe here
mostly just on collecting data by
playing itself or playing by humans
so so experiences mostly means data and
there's a concept called performance
performance measure which is kind of
important in machine learning of course
there's no unique performance measure
for different tasks you have different
measures of performance but but the
metric performance is the this metric
the performance measure is pretty
important in here you can call it
um the performance measure could be the
winning rate it could be the the winning
rate Plus for example the the number of
steps you played right you probably want
to win as fast as possible in some other
cases the performance measure that could
be How likely You can predict something
very accurately right so you can Define
many performance measures and
um I guess actually you know immersion
learning you know if you look at the
research you know some papers about you
know understanding what's the right
performance measure what's the right way
to formulate our problem and some of the
papers are about that given the
performance measure how do you make the
performance you know as best as possible
so
um and there is
so and also there is this um last
sentence where it says that if it's
performance at the task in t as measured
by P improves with experience what does
improves with experience E I think it
means that if you have more experiences
if you have more data then your
algorithm should have better performance
so so that in some sense is a kind of
like a a kind of like a evidence for you
to learn something from the experiences
right if you have more and more
experiences you your performance is not
improved maybe that doesn't really mean
that you learn something right that
could probably just means that you are
you just progress you just program some
kind of like explicit program some
strategy and that strategy probably
wouldn't improve as you have more
experiences right so so in some sense
this last few words indicates that you
are learning uh from the experiences
all right so I guess you know the final
thing is that the tasks right so here
the tasks is really winning
um is this kind of context of playing
the game right so
um and we're gonna see actually a many
different type of tasks uh actually just
in this lecture right so there are tasks
about predicting
um the the labels of predicting
something given the the input or the
task could be finding out certain
structures in the data or the tasks
could be something like this where you
want you want to kind of make decisions
about you know how do you play the game
in any case feel free to stop me just
with your hand then I'm happy to answer
any questions
um this lecture is supposed to be very
high level so
um feel free to ask any questions
so uh I guess um speaking of tasks right
so this is um a pretty simplistic view
based on tasks you know how do you have
a taxonomy of machine learning right so
I don't think everyone agrees with this
um um but it's a it's a reasonable
Baseline you know as a as a kind of like
a high level kind of like taxonomy so I
think surprise learning and surprise
learning and reinforcement I'm going to
introduce uh this um uh separately but
it's not like these tasks are completely
uh separated right so probably the real
figure would be like this right so
there's some overlaps right so in
reinforced learning problem you have to
use supervised learning as a component
and and as I said like many machine
Learners where people are trying to
figure out what's the right way to
formulate the question to solve the
applications right so maybe for some
applications you have to use two of this
together so
um they are not necessarily only tasks
but sometimes there also kind of can be
viewed as you know tools or methods to
solve your question right so maybe some
questions requires you know using for
requires a formulation that involves
both of these three ingredients in some
way
um but as a first other bet you can
think of them as three separate or
roughly separate kind of type of tasks
so I'm going to introduce supervised
learning first so
um
surprise learning I guess
we are actually in the lecture we are
going to use this um uh house price
prediction uh as a kind of a running
example so the kind of idea is that I'm
going to have a relatively abstract way
to introduce this but you can use this
you can think of the the house price
prediction as the kind of application so
what you are given is a data set that
contains n samples and what are these n
samples it's n samples are in pairs
um of you know numbers or empires of
like vectors where X could be a vector
or a number let's say x is a number and
Y is also number so you have n pairs of
X Y numbers and you can actually draw
these numbers you know
um here you know have a Sketcher plot
right so every you know cross is really
just One X by pair
and the X could mean
um
so ask means the hot I guess this as
shown here in the in the caption or um
so the square feet is X and the Y is the
price right so basically for every
example it's a pair of square feet and
price you are trying to use the square
feet
X to predict the price y That's the task
and and this data set is called you know
using Tom Mitchell's language this data
set is the experience in a problem more
more than language we call this data set
of data so
so basically our goal is to learn from
the data set how to predict the price
given uh the square feet of the house
and so so basically if x is 800 then
what is y and 8 this x you know might
not be seen in the data set right if you
ask is already you know show up already
shows up in the data setting it's easy
you can just read it off but X could be
something that you haven't seen in the
data set
so and you know one of the way that you
probably have seen this you know in some
of the other lectures or other courses
where you can do a linear regression you
fit a linear line and then when you
predict you just read off the
corresponding number on this linear line
what is the corresponding Y where X is
800.
so and of course you can do um
other things for example you can try to
fade a quadratic line right so which
actually in this case in this example uh
this artificial example I I created you
know a quadratic line problem with fill
the data better
um and in lecture two and three I think
our goal would be
um to discuss you know how do you fit a
linear model and all you how to create a
quadratic model for the data to predict
the house price
of course you know the house price
prediction is only your application you
can imagine you know many other
applications where you are giving a data
set of X by Pairs and your goal is to
predict y given X
for example you know
um we can even we can just simply make
the house price prediction problem a
little more complicated right so we said
that in the previous lecture in the
previous slide we use the the size to
predict the price but actually you know
probably more about the house right so
and you know for example the lot size
and maybe you know other things right
then for example suppose you also know
the lot size then your goal could be to
predict the price using size and loss
size and we call this kind of like input
different dimensions of the input X
features right so size is one feature
and loss size is another feature so now
you have two features of the the
particular house and you want to predict
the price based on the two features and
now your data if you draw them
um and then there will be three
dimensional X1 X2 and Y and then you can
kind of plot them in these three
dimensional graph
um and as I said you know the
um the the kind of the the things you
know in the class time right the size
and loss size is called features or
input and in this case this features is
two-dimensional and typically people
call the price label or output and you
are trying to find a function which Maps
the input to the output
um
so actually another heads up is that in
machine learning almost every concept
has more than one terms for them so
you're gonna see that you know some
people call this feature some called
people call this inputs and in some
other cases probably you have other
names for for digital things we'll try
to be kind of
um uh comprehensive like I'm gonna tell
you what are the different names but
we're going to use one of them I think
in the lectures mostly we probably we're
going to use input because input and
output is a little bit less ambiguous
actually features sometimes could mean
other things as well
um and again now everything is the same
in terms of the mathematical notations
the only difference is that now your ex
is a two-dimensional thing let me
explain the notation here a little bit
which will be used consistently in the
lecture so the superscript here denotes
the which example uh you're talking
about whether it's the index for the
example and the subscript here denotes
the demand the coordinates of the of the
data so x superscript i is a
two-dimensional vector and the X
superscript I sub 1 is the first
coordinate of the two-dimensional vector
yeah
and also sometimes
like a website that the price the Y is
called labels and outputs and sometimes
they also because they're also called
supervicious or generally if you say
supervisions that means the set of
labels right that's why this is called
supervised learning because you do
observe uh some
um labels
um in the in the in the in the data set
and also the data set you know sometimes
people call it tuning data set
um or data set
um or training examples you know there
are multiple names
um for the for it
any questions
and you can also have like high
dimensional features like before we only
have two Dimensions but actually in many
cases you know
if you have a house listed on
online right for sale then you probably
know a lot more about the house and then
you can have a high dimensional Vector
uh say d dimensional vector and each
Dimension means something right maybe
the number of floors the condition the
ZIP code so and so forth and you use
this High dimensional Vector to predict
the Y
um the label that you are trying to
predict
and in lecture six and seven we are
going to talk about you know infinite
dimensional features actually so in some
cases you can uh have like you know uh
you can combine these features into not
a lot of more other features where you
can say I don't use X Y as my features
but I actually use X1 times X2 as my
features right leaving size times a lot
of size I don't think that makes a lot
of sense for this application but in
some other cases maybe you can kind of
like take the product of your two
um raw features right two dimension of
the input you have and use that as a as
a new feature right so and we're going
to talk about how do you deal with
infant dimensional features
as well
um and in some of the other lectures
we're going to talk about you know how
to select features Based on data
um so maybe not all of these features
are useful if you use all of these
features then maybe you can overfit
which is the concept we're going to talk
uh talk about you may kind of like be
confused if there are too many
informations
um available so you may select something
that is most important right so maybe
um I don't know like all of this seems
to be important but maybe there's other
features that are not important for
price prediction
right and there's another concept that
I'm going to introduce in the in the
first lecture we'll talk about this
um later as well so
um typically there are two typos two
types of supervised problems so based on
this
distinction is based on what kind of
labels uh you have right so
um one type is called regression problem
so these are problems where your label y
is um is a real number
so you are predicting for example
something like a price
right so this is a continuous variable
and there's another type of questions
which is called classification and these
are cases where the labels is a discrete
variable what does that mean that means
that your labels are probably like you
have two labels yes and no right so you
just have like this label that is just a
discrete set with two choices yes and no
um for example like in this case you can
change the question like you know if
you're given the size and lost size you
can ask you know whether this house
what's the type of this horse or this
residence right is it a house or
townhouse
right so it's not a continuous
prediction problem it's really just the
predicting one of the two choices
and you can make this problem more
complicated for example you can have
much more choices here
um not only just two choices and then in
this case you know the way that we can
kind of like
um kind of plot the data set
um one way to product is the following
so now you have a two-dimensional uh
graph where uh the x is the size and the
Y is the the Lost size
and then for every dot you have a you
know if it's a triangle it means it's
house and if it's a circle it means a
townhouse
and that's how you kind of like
visualize the at least one way of how to
visualize a classification data set
where the labels are discrete you just
use the triangle and circle
um to to indicate the label of this
example
and and and then you know the kind of
questions you want to solve sorry my
animation the question you want to solve
is that now if you give me a house which
is a two-dimensional Vector with the
size and loss size given as it as the
input and you're asking what's the type
of this uh house
um so whether it's a house or town house
and one of the way to do it is that you
say you
okay now I see okay so you can fade a
linear classifier that distinguish these
two type of dots and then your answer
here would be naturally house because it
sounds like it's on the right side of
the this correct this side of the the
line so it's probably should be
consistent with all the other uh
examples on the same side of the line
so I guess lecture three and four will
be about classification problems
and the next few slides I'm going to
talk about some broader applications of
machine learning which we don't
necessarily will cover I think image
classification I think probably we're
going to have one homework questions on
image classification so the kind of the
type of question is that you are given
all of these images and every image has
a label which describes the content of
this uh the main object in this image of
course you know in other cases you know
you may have multiple objects in the
same image but here let's say let's
focus on a simple setting where every
image has a single important object and
then your label is basically describing
what this object is and you're giving
this data set this is actually a real
data set you know created by Stanford
people like by Professor Philistine so
which is called imagenet this is a very
important data set that you probably
should remember the name of it because
this is pretty much the data set that in
some sense make deep learning take off
in the last five to ten years
um like before
after the creation of this data set and
some of the new
um deep learning
algorithms with new artworks I think in
the last five to ten years we saw
um like machine learning took off and
are able to kind of we were able to make
a lot of progress because of the data
set
and speak of the data set here I'm only
trying to say what's the format or
what's kind of the task right so
basically your ex is some raw pixels of
the images where you just represent this
image as a sequence of numbers actually
here's a matrix of numbers and then
um your Y is the the main object of the
of the image
so and you can have other kind of tasks
in vision for example object
localization or detection right so give
an image you can ask you know how do I
localize you know
um find out each of the important
objects right with the bounding box
we're not going to cover anything like
this because these are more specific to
the vision applications
and
right so so here I guess the the thing
is that your why becomes like a a
bounding box right so so how do you
present this box
um you know you don't have to know this
but you know if you are interested the
way to present the box is to present a
box by uh the the coordinate here and
the coordinate here and these two
coordinates four numbers by two points
four numbers will describe the box so
basically a y will become four numbers
uh instead of just one number
and actually you can have actually more
complex labels or y's in other
applications for example in natural
language processing which is the area to
deal with you know language problems so
for example machine translation you can
have this problem where you you want to
translate
um for example English to Chinese uh and
your ex is
I don't know what happens with my
pointer okay so your X is the the
English sentence and your Y is the
um
is the uh the Chinese sentence right all
sentences in other languages and now you
can see that the Y even though Y is a
discrete set the the family of y's is
the family of all possible sentences
um in
uh in Chinese right but so so why looks
like this quiz but Y is much more
complicated than the house versus
townhouse application right so you have
so many choices of why like almost like
exponential or even number of choices so
then you have to deal with them in some
different ways I think we're going to
cover a little bit about machine
translation or this kind of questions uh
in one of the lectures that we uh added
on this year
um I guess Chris mentioned that like
we're going to talk a little bit about
like a large language models uh for
language applications
but on the other hand you know this
course only covers the basics of the
foundational techniques of surprise
learning so we're going to talk about
language applications but if you really
care about the particular applications
how to solve them the best way then you
probably would have to take some other
uh more kind of like a specific courses
um for those particular applications
okay so before I move on to unspressed
learning any questions about surprise
learning
so would you say it's a regression
problem or classification problem I
think I would say it's a classification
problem because
why the formula of Y is still
technically discrete
right because you still have like a a
finite number of possible y's because
um I assume you can say the number of
sentences
um Chinese let's say the name of Chinese
sentences is finance right even though
the number is very large but this is a
good question because you know you
cannot choose this as a simple as a you
have to treat it in some slightly
different way differently from the the
most vanilla classification problems
because if you view this as the vanilla
classification problems then you're
going to get into other issues right so
um just because the set of wires is too
big
when you use infant dimensional features
so
um I think I might not have a very clear
answer right now because this does
depends on a little bit on some of the
other things we're going to teach but I
think generally basically sometimes you
don't know what so basically okay first
of all how do you create infinite number
of features right like so you you have
to create them from X right so for
example I guess I I think I alluded to
this a little bit at some point so
for example suppose you have this number
of features right maybe D is a hundred
so now you have 100 features how do you
create more features you're going to use
combinations of the existing features
right so
um and you can come up with a lot of
different combinations
um so you can have like for example x d
to the power
of K right and K could be any integer
right so that's how you create infinite
number of features and why you want to
use them sometimes it's because you
don't know which one is the best so you
just say I'm going to create all the
possible features I can think of and I'm
going to like the machine learning model
to decide which feature is the most
useful or how do you combine these
features so that's why we use
info-dimensional features in most of the
cases in reality you don't have to
literally with infinite dimensional
features after you run the algorithm you
found out that some features are more
important than others but before you run
an algorithm we don't know which one is
useful so you like the algorithm the
machine learning algorithm to figure out
which one is the most useful
and actually one of the interesting is
that even the dimension of the features
is infinite it doesn't really mean that
your runtime has to be infinite so there
are some tricks to reduce the actual
runtime so even though you are
implicitly learning with infinimental
features actually your algorithm or
runtime and memory all of these are
actually finite and and actually
sometimes they could be pretty fast in
some in some cases
so these are great questions yeah thanks
for all the questions
any other questions
okay so the the second part of the um
the course will be about Enterprise
Learning I think Chris will probably
um give about five lectures on and space
learning so and space learning the if
you still use the host
um house prediction kind of data set as
an example the basic idea is that you
know you are only given a data set
without labels you only see the access
but not wise right so you don't know how
this house is you know in a data set are
sold
um in in the past
so so what happens is you know it's you
still using this townhouse versus house
example right so if you are supervised
and you have this triangles and and and
circles here to indicate what what are
the labels but
you guys should stand here so but uh um
if it's answered you just don't have
this this part of the information right
you just see kind of like a
this this bunch of dogs here in the in
the scatter plot but as as you will see
right even you just see this right as a
human if once you see this you somehow
tell that okay this bunch of points here
is very different from this bunch of
points here so maybe there are two type
of residents here uh going on even
as a human right even though you don't
see the the triangle and circle you
still kind of are able to tell there's
something going on there right so that's
the kind of the the nature of science
learning we want to be able to discover
interesting structure in the data
without uh knowledge about the the
labels right so you want to figure out
the structure hidden in the data
so
to find some interest instructional data
so for example in this case you know
what you can do is that you can try to
Cluster
um
cluster these points into groups right
you want to divide these points into
groups and what you want to say that
each group probably have some kind of
like a similar structure right so this
probably doesn't sound like a very good
clustering because
um at least as a human being you
probably wouldn't cast it like this but
maybe you you like a good algorithm
problem would produce this right so if
you produce this then essentially you
figure out
and there are two type of residents and
this data set even though you don't know
the the name of these two happy
presidents right because the algorithm
wouldn't know townhouse or house is two
words but the algorithms knows there are
two type of things going on here in the
in the data set
um and in lecture 12 and 13 we are going
to talk about a few different kind of
algorithms for discovering the
structures okay means classroom and
mixture of gaussians
um and there are other kind of
applications uh for example
um I think this is a paper by
um Daphne Collins group who is a Adjunct
professor here at Stanford so so here
the kind of applications about Gene
clustering so I think the idea is that
you have a lot of individuals and for
this particular part of the genes you
know you can group uh the genes of
individuals into different groups
so and and you can see that um
um I guess even basically you can kind
of see
I'm not sure what's going on with my
foreign
you can see that there are some kind of
clusters here and it turns out that each
of these clusters you know corresponds
to how the individuals would react to a
certain kind of medicine right so and
once you kind of like can group people
you know into groups then you can
probably apply the right type of kind of
like
um treatment on to each type of people
um now here is another example which is
probably a little more kind of easier to
understand you know like uh so so the
the the the type of kind of question is
called latency meta-analysis which I
don't expect you to understand what each
of these means you know it's just a kind
of like a name iOS a so the idea is that
you kind of like look at a bunch of
documents and every document has a lot
of words right so and you look at which
word show up in which document for how
many types so each entry here supposed
to pick one entry it means how how often
the word power shows up in this
corresponding column the document 16 is
it document document six there right so
every answer is how often the word shows
up in the in the in the document and if
you see this you know it then sounds
like there's any pattern here right so
what's the structure it's unclear but if
you use the right machine learning
algorithm what happens is that you can
reorder or regroup this kind of words
and documents in the following way
you see the video is working
right so basically you permute the
documents and words and and then you see
this kind of like interesting and
sometimes block diagonal structure not
very prominently but still kind of
interesting enough and now you can see
each of these blocks has some particular
interesting meaning for example here
this group of documents and words has
this it's clearly about something about
space
kind of like shuttles right so shuttle
space launch booster these are all about
kind of like a like um
um like a like a space traveling kind of
things right so and so basically you
know that this kind of four words have
similar meanings and these four
documents or three documents are about
this this topic so by doing this you in
some sense you know at least in this
application you can figure out the kind
of the topics of uh in in your data set
right so you can figure out probably
here there's one topic two one two three
four five topics and each topic is more
likely to associate to a certain type of
words and every document is most likely
about one topic and sometimes it's about
two topics and then what you what
happens is that once you figure out
these kind of topics and then you can
use some humans to kind of like
interpret each of these topics what each
of these topics are and then give a new
document you can figure out you know
what topic this new document is about
and this actually is very popular
um tool in many of the social science
because in Social guys
actually even myself you know was
involved in some of the projects in my
PhD so the social scientists they have
some texts right they maybe have like a
lot of like a maybe blog posts about
politics right and they want to
understand you know what each
for example what trends happens you know
in the blog post that so suppose you
want to understand that and then you
have to know you know what are the kind
of topics about each of the blog posts
where you don't want to kind of like
label them each one by one because they
maybe they have like a million blog
posts right so they use this to kind of
group the blog post in certain ways and
then they can do statistics to
understand what happens with all of
these blog posts and this kind of
applies to other kind of things Beyond
politics you can have like actually you
can even apply this to I think many
things like you know history
um what else you know
um like psychologists so and so forth
right so um and this was actually an
algorithm discovered probably 20 years
ago or even maybe earlier than that
maybe 30 years ago and it was pretty uh
popular still like a um in in social
science
of course there are even more advanced
you know algorithms they stay single
Beyond this
um
um which we're also going to discuss
right so this is actually one of the the
more recent kind of advancement I think
this was like a around 2013 2014 about
seven eight years ago so what happens
here is that
um you have a very very large unlabeled
data set which is the which is called
Wikipedia
um so
um so you just download all the
documents from Wikipedia there's no
other human labeling right they are just
just raw documents and what you do is
that you learn from these documents
using some algorithms and what you can
eventually produce is the so-called word
embeddings so you can represent all the
Every Word by a corresponding vector and
why you want to do that the reason is
that these vectors has
um basically a kind of like the the
numerical representations of the of the
discrete word and and there are some
nice properties about these factors that
captures the semantic meanings of the
words so so what happens is that similar
words will have similar vectors and and
also the that's that's what I mean by
like a the word is encoding the vector
so similar word would have similar
vectors and also the relationship
between words will be encoded in the
directions of the vectors this sounds a
little bit abstract maybe it's easier
with this figure
so
um actually this kind of happens in
reality right so if you look at the
vectors each point is the vector for
that word right so Italy has a vector
and the vector let's say is this point
and France has the vector and Germany
has a vector so you'll find out that the
vectors for all the countries they are
somewhat kind of similar in similar
directions right so they are so for
example suppose you have another country
USA then you probably would find out the
the point somewhere here like nearby
right so all the country uh has vectors
that are similar in similar that are
that are in similar directions and all
the capitals are also in similar
directions so this is what I mean by the
um the the vectors kind of encode some
kind of semantic
um uh like a similarity between the
words and also interestingly the
directions also encode some kind of uh
relationship so here what happens is
that if you look at the difference of
the
um uh between Italy and Rome right so
you kind of this this direction right
this is the difference between Italy and
Rome and you also do the same thing for
Paris and France and Berlin Germany
you'll see that the three directions
they are very uh similar to each other
they are kind of like in these parallel
positions
so
um so in so
um at least one application of this is
that if you want to know
um suppose you are given let's say us
right so which is a vector here right
and you want to know what is the capital
of U.S where is the capital of U.S you
probably should you go along this
direction to search for points and
that's likely to be the capital maybe
you'll find DC or Washington I guess
you'll find DC there um because I think
Washington is ambiguous which is a
little trickier
um
I guess that's why I don't have the
actually this is an interesting thing
right so uh if you have the the
Washington director uh would be tricky
right it's not clear where the the
vector for Washington will be not clear
where it will be because Washington has
multiple meanings right so it's a state
it's a it's a person is you know
um so so actually this is a sometimes
you know you have this ambiguity and and
then you can have this kind of like more
kind of complex clusterance of the words
so for example I think
um
so here I guess what happens is that you
know you can also use these vectors to
Cluster the words into groups
um so for example uh you have this kind
of groups kind of these words you know
like scientific words
some of which which some of which I
don't even know and then you can use the
the casting algorithms for the vectors
to figure out what they uh what kind of
topics or what kind of like scientific
areas they belongs to right and and you
can also have hierarchical clusterings
uh to deal with kind of certain kind of
overlaps because for example
mathematical physics probably would be
closer to the physics vectors and math
factors on both right some somewhere in
the middle of the math and physics
vectors
so
um
um so so so there are this kind of like
an interesting many kind of different
interesting structures in in all of
these word vectors which you can uh
leverage to solve your tasks
I'm a little conflict here just because
you know to exactly do all of this it
requires a little bit more uh uh things
you know
um that we haven't you know discussing
but we will discuss some of this in
later lectures
so and and most recently
um in the last two or three years
there's a new
um kind of like uh say Trend or kind of
like there's a new breakthrough in
machine learning which is
um these large language models I think
many of us are very excited about it you
know Chris has mentioned about that
um and and I stand for new health
actually
um a lot of people you know working on
these large language models
um and roughly speaking these are
machine learning models for language and
they are learned on very large scale
data sets you know for example Wikipedia
I say
um discussed before or sometimes even
bigger than Wikipedia so you can
download you know
um a trillion you know words or maybe
like a like a like a 10 trillion words
you know on on online because there are
so many kind of like online documents
and you collect all of this
um documents and you learn a gigantic
model on top of it you know these are
gonna be very very costly even tuning
the single model would probably cost you
like a 10 million dollars you know
um so just for one time so they are they
are very costly but they are very
powerful because they can be used for
many different purposes and in
particularly here I'm talking about this
breakthrough called gpt3
you're gonna heard this name probably
pretty often uh not very often like in
the lecture
um uh like pretty often in general like
a
um in the next few years I think uh or
you probably already heard of it in the
in the lecture we're going to talk about
this like in one lecture so GPD three is
this gigantic model and they can do a
lot of things so I'm downloading this is
a example of from there on blog post so
you can use this gpt3 to generate uh
stories I think here what happens is
that you you give
human some person writes this paragraph
about you know something right so like
some I guess mountains or valleys and
then
um the model the Machinery model can
just generate some story and some kind
of like very coherent and meaningful
text afterwards and you cannot probably
if you don't tell you these are
generated by machines you probably
wouldn't know that they are generated by
machines you probably guess this is
written by
um on some some authors
so that's one application you can one
use one way to use this model to
generate stories and you can also use
this model to answer questions right so
here
um you you give you give this model this
long paragraph and then you can ask
um it's kind of like a SAT I'm not sure
like this is kind of like GRE questions
I'm not sure whether all of you know GRE
but like
um so like these are kind of like just
basic questions answering about the past
passage right you can ask you know
what's what is the most popular uh um
politics in uh in Finland and and this
will this is this is the information you
can find in a document and and they
would answer the right thing
um so that's another application and you
can also use this to do other things for
example you can say you can just just
write in the text say please unscramble
the letters into a word and write that
word and then you give this to the model
and the model will just change the uh
the orders of the letters to to make it
a meaningful word and you can ask you
know for example this is not like a
simple numerical questions what is 95
times 45 and it gives you the right
answer
and all of this are not like so so
what's the amazing about this is not
because it can solve all of these tasks
just each of these tasks the amazing
thing is that you learn on this
unlimited site this gigantic and enabled
set you didn't specify what tasks you
want to solve right the only thing you
see is this gigantic data and then the
single model can be used to solve
multiple tasks just by interacting it
with different things right if you want
to solve this task you just write it in
the human interpretable language 95
times 44 45 and if you want to solve
another task you just do something else
a slightly different kind of like
phrasing
um then they can be used to solve
multiple tasks and that's that's why we
call them Foundation models
um at least you know your paper in a
white paper written by Stanford people
um so um so in some sense there are kind
of Foundations uh for uh they can be
used for a wide range of applications uh
without
um further and sometimes without a lot
of like further uh changes right so the
model itself can be can do a lot of work
um for many tasks
okay so I guess I'm supposed to stop
like for 30 wait
445 right yeah sorry like uh
um okay so I still have some time any
questions
sorry
um like a um
right so I guess um maybe one if I
understand the question correctly so one
concern is that whether this 95 times 45
already show up in the Corpus but maybe
you just memorize it that's one
possibility but I think that's that's
not the case so of course some of the
numerical
um problems like some of these
multiplication problems show up in the
Corpus christ you will find one document
online about you know what is 12 times
35 but you wouldn't find I think you
wouldn't find the uh documents about all
pairs of like multiplications
um so like multiplications of pairs of
like two digits numbers I don't think
you'll find all of them
um so so there's some kind of
extrapolations where you see some of
course you have to see something right
so that you can learn from them right so
you probably have seen a lot of kind of
like a numerical
um uh operations like all kind of like
mathematics the formulas in the document
but then you can in the in the tuning
Corpus and then you kind of extrapolate
to other uh other instances right like
so you learn from
um some basic stuff and then you learn
like then you can use the model to
Output multiplication so for example
longer uh digits does it make sense does
that answer the question
right so how do you make sure that the
like uh by pollution I guess you mean
that how do you make sure that in the
tuning Corpus they are not all pairs of
double digits right so I think they do
run some tests to check that so of
course you cannot make sure
I guess is that what you mean by
pollution or you mean by pollution you
mean like something wrong about the
false information
right right okay
right so that's a great question right
so I think abstract is speaking the
question is about you know how do you
make sure your training corpers don't
doesn't have wrong information for you
all right so I think we you know I think
they definitely they are wrong
information in the Corpus right I think
what happens is that they are probably
more correct information than raw
information and and you somehow kind of
reconcile between them and you kind of
pick the right thing
um so that's largely what's going on but
of course you know if you are very
specific about you know so this this
area called Data poisoning so you can
actually specifically change your tuning
data in some special way actually you
just change a small number of training
data so that your model learns something
completely wrong so that's that's
actually possible so but that requires a
kind of adversarial change of the tuning
Corpus so so on one side this is a very
bad thing because you know if someone do
something out of a serial online and you
use those kind of documents to train
your model that's that's a huge risk on
the other hand you have because you have
to right so at least right now like uh
like the it's not it's like a this kind
of like a adversary Point thing is not
happening very often just because it's
not very easy to achieve them
thank you
okay any other questions
okay cool yeah these are all great
questions like I like to have more
questions uh that's great so
um okay so the last part is about
reinforcement learning
um this will consist of probably two or
three lectures at the end of the
um at the end of the course so the main
idea of reinforcement is that here the
tasks roughly speaking about learning to
make sequential decisions so I think
there are two things right one thing is
that you are making decisions so before
in both Superstar and express learning
in some sense you are making predictions
right at least in supervisoring it's
pretty clear you are predicting wise but
here you are talking about decisions and
what's the difference between predicting
decisions and like the decisions and and
predictions the decisions has uh
long-term consequences right so for
example if you play chess right so you
you make some move and that move will
affect your future uh like it affect the
future right so so you have to to think
about long-term ramifications and also
this is a sequential decision so so
you're going to take a a sequence of
steps right so when you take the first
step you have to consider you know what
this step will change my game and what
happens in the future so so that's why
you can see that you know this kind of
like reinforcement algorithms are mostly
trying to solve these kind of questions
where you have to make a sequence of
decisions so for example when you
self-go right you probably heard of
alphago and another example is like for
example you want to learn a robot so if
you want to control the robot you have
to take a sequence of decisions right
how do you change the joints you know
how do you kind of like a control uh
like actually there are always multiple
kind of like uh things you can control
for a robot and how do you control all
of them in a sequential way so here I'm
I'm showing this in a simulation
environment so this is a so-called
humanoid which is kind of a robot that
imitates a human so and the goal is to
you can control a lot of joints
um in this in this robot and your goal
is that you want to make this robot be
able to walk to the right as fast as
possible
and and this is what happens uh how the
kind of what happens with the
reinforcement algorithm learning here so
it's kind of like trials and errors to
some extent so what you do is you say
you first try some actions right you
first try to kind of like do something
like this and and then you figure out
that this didn't work well right it's
false and then you go back to say I'm
going to change my strategy in some way
right so I know that some strategy is
not going to work I'm going to try some
other strategies and maybe I know some
strategies is actually partially working
because at least the robot the humanoid
is is doing something right it does walk
to to the right for one step it just
didn't keep the balance you know some
part is good some part is bad and then
you try to go back to change your
strategy and then you probably can walk
a little further
something like this
right and then I guess I'm going to fast
forward to iteration 80 I think 80 works
I forgot whether I have an oh actually
80 still doesn't work perfectly
you can see it's working in a weird way
um
yeah so and I think at iteration
210 I think it's
it can keep working but still it sounds
that it sounds very natural but this is
a problem like you shouldn't expect that
the humanoid work as natural as humans
um partly because they are different
there are many different things right so
like maybe for the robot this is optimal
strategy you know
that's possible but of course I don't
think it's the optimal strategy but it's
possible that optimal strategy for the
robot is not the same as the option
strategy for for us
so and generally as I alluded to so the
kind of like the the very high level
idea of reinforcement algorithm is that
you have this kind of like Loop
um between training and data collection
so so the algorithm so before in
Supersonic and Einstein we always have a
data set where someone give you a data
set and that's all you have right you
cannot say okay give more examples of
the house uh house prices right so you
have to work with what we are given but
here uh in the reinforcement formulation
you often can collect data interactively
I see some questions it's a question
sorry okay um okay so so here you often
can collect data interactively so
meaning that you try like for example in
the humanoid example you try some
strategy and you see that humanoid false
then that's the data you see
additionally right so then you can
incorporate new data back to your
training algorithm and then change your
strategy right so you have this kind of
loop where you in one one side you try
the strategy and collect feedbacks and
the other side you improve your strategy
based on new feedback so in some sense
you have a data set that is growing over
time the the longer you try the more
data points you're gonna see and and
that will help you to learn
um I'm better and better
so I guess so um
Okay so
I guess that's my last slice about
reinforced learning any questions
[Music]
oh oh sorry oh uh or after like an empty
like the information is completely right
right so is the feedback uh uh seen
after each type of decision or is it
after something else right so so there
are many different formulations this is
a great question so so the most typical
way typical formulation is that you see
the feedback right after the decision
you make
um but that sometimes it's not realistic
for example let me see what are the
examples so
um
I I think okay maybe I'm blanking on
what are what are the best examples to
show but in some cases you don't have
the feedback right right after and
sometimes even you have the feedback
right after the decision you cannot
change your strategy right after
decision so
um just because for example there is a
computational limit or you have to
really do something physical to change
your strategy on a humanoid right or
maybe there's some communication
constraints so uh so there are multiple
kind of different formulations
reinforcement learning I think if you
have delayed reward I think that's
called the delayed reward problem and
sometimes you also have this so-called
deployment wronged in the sense that
um so this notion of number of
deployment means that you can only
update your strategy for for example
five types right so you cannot just
constantly change your strategy and then
you can ask this question what's the
best way to to do this for example I
guess one example is that
um you suppose you are using
reinforcement to control a nuclear plant
right so you probably don't want to say
that you just keep telling you you run
algorithm like a
um like you run algorithm and the
algorithm keep telling the nuclear plant
to change their strategy to control them
right like every day that sounds like
risky and and also kind of like
inefficient you know there are many
problems with it right so probably
you're gonna say that I have to do some
experiments you know for a little bit
for six months and then I figured one
strategy that I almost guarantee
um uh I can guarantee that this new
strategy is working better than the old
one and then I deploy it and then
collect some new feedback
quite so and also I guess maybe another
thing this is a great question and
another thing
um I I would like to mention is that in
many of these problems you know there
are multiple uh Criterion for example
for reinforcement if you want to control
the nuclear plant there's a safety
concern right so then you have to have
to care about whether your strategy is
safe or not right for the human noise
probably it's fine for the human not to
fall down you know to some extent but
still you cannot really let it fall down
so often because it will hurt your
Hardware right so it is frustrating the
other constraints for example there are
constraints about you know how how long
is the tuning type right that's the
typical metric and there is also a
constraint about how kind of like a
powerful or how kind of multi-purpose on
these models are right How likely they
can solve multiple tasks So So
eventually like uh this is a very
um like especially if you look at a
research Community there are different
people care about different metrics um
just because all of these metrics you
know have their own applications right
so
um so so this so it's the the real kind
of scenario is much more complicated
than this in some sense
okay so I guess um in um there are a few
other lectures about other topics in the
course
um which are actually in between some of
these
um big topics so one of the topics we
are going to spend two lectures on is
deep learning Basics so deep learning if
you heard of the word so maybe some of
you have heard of it so deep learning is
um the technique of using the so-called
new neural networks uh is your model
parametrization so
um so this is this can be used together
with
um
all of these tasks right it's kind of
like a technique that can be used in
reinforcement that can use in Surprise
learning and express learning and in
many other situations so and this is
something that um
um is very important because you know
because of deep learning uh took off
around 2014 2013 in the last seven years
we see this tremendous progress of
machine learning because of these
techniques a lot of things you know are
enabled by this different techniques
so uh and we're gonna also discuss a
little bit about learning theory uh just
for one or two lectures
um so in some sense actually we don't
really talk that much about the the the
core theory in some sense the goal here
is to
um uh understand uh some of the kind of
like trade-offs of some of the decisions
that you should do when you train the
algorithms right so what's the best way
to select features what's the best way
to make your test error as small as
possible and also we're going to have a
lecture on how do you really use some of
these insights to tune
um an ml model in practice you know what
kind of decisions
um I as though as the machine learning
as a the as the algorithm implementer
you know what compositions you have to
pay attention to so and so forth
so
um
I guess we're gonna have a guest lecture
on on the broader aspects of machine
learning especially robustness and
fairness
um I guess machine learning has a lot of
societal impact especially because
machine learning Now is working you can
really use it you know in practice and
it will create some kind of societal
issues actually a lot of societal issues
um and and these are things that we
should pay attention to I'm not an
expert in this area we're going to have
a guest lecture James though
who work a lot on this to talk about
fairness and robustness of machine
learning models
okay I guess this is uh
um all I want to say for today